[Music]
hello good to be here thanks for coming
so yeah this is me at work I am the
original author of patchy calcite
although there's a lot of developers
they's very active in open-source and
I'm an architect at looker so the the
talk today is kind of going to be kind
of a meandering selection of topics what
I'm what I'm trying to do is my
background is in building relational
databases
in particular query optimization but you
know other other things as well and I'm
drawing the parallels between the kind
of data engineering you need to do to
build the whole system you know a system
which includes data sources from perhaps
you know third-party services all the
way through the data center and an
interactive analytic system comparing
that to what's going on inside and the
internals of the relational database and
looking at how we can apply some of
those techniques some of the learnings
to make the pipeline run more
efficiently and make the users happier
so first of all just let's look at what
a database does and what the database is
so I guess the the first question
everyone asked is in or in order to
define what a relational database is or
what a database management system is you
should look at the alternative which is
just a file system with a program on top
of it how is that different the answer
is it's not really very different the
database is storing its data in files
under the covers in the case of a file
system you write a program in Python or
C or whatever your favorite language is
the database also has a program that's
running and that program is a query the
difference is that the program that you
run against the database is in the
higher-level language and that gets
translated into an internal program an
execution plan which is what the
database actually uses to access the
data so you've introduced this level of
indirection
between the actual that the the question
that the user asks and what the database
actually execute and that level of
indirection is super important the files
are probably in fairly similar formats
in both in both systems so let's suppose
we want to change that we want to do a
program which is a joint between two
files which will you know largest write
100 million records in each it's
impossible to write a program that does
an efficient join between those two
files or rather it's difficult but it's
easier if we just say let's let's just
sort the two files on that common key
then we can write a very efficient
program because it just does emerge if
you are the programmer that was
responsible for that test that's a
significant effort because you know you
need to rebuild these files and you need
to rewrite your program if you're using
a database management system that's
extremely easy because you just write a
join query and perhaps the first time
you run it the data isn't sorted and the
join query takes awhile and then you say
well let's create an index on this and
the query runs really fast so because
the database has been generated
regenerates that program every time you
ask the query and furthermore it
regenerates it based on the data
structures that are available you get
this you get this performance
improvement so the database system is
literally managing the data and
furthermore the database doesn't when
you create an index of course you're not
resourcing you're not you're not taking
you're not taking the same file and
sourcing you creating another file which
is a redundant copy of the data in a
different sort order because it may turn
out that the file in its original sort
order or in its original organization
it's still you know really useful for
other kinds of queries so that's another
kind of recurring feature in database
management systems is redundant copies
of data so there's various kinds of
value that the DBMS adds I mentioned
abstraction this fact that there's a
high-level language which translates to
a low-level language you have to have
that declarative language a
you know you can't you can't translate
for example pi it's difficult to
translate a Python a Python program into
something lower-level because it's it's
difficult to understand and rewrite
something which is a Turing powerful
language sequel is sufficiently
unpowered
we're able to fully understand it and
optimize it you need a query planner to
do that transformation taking into
account the algorithms that are
available and statistics the database
makes it easy to reorganize the data
which is changing sort orders we'll talk
some more about that later
and then a bunch of other stuff like
governance metadata and I'm gonna
propose adaptability which is the
ability of the system to respond to
changes in workload so respond if people
are querying a some data that never
queried before are they're querying it
in ways that haven't been queried before
the database will basically self tune
because of the way it's built so that it
starts running faster so now let's look
at the I know the what I claim is an
analogous problem of the data pipeline
so here's a simplified diagram of a data
pipeline you're reading from sources
perhaps these are cloud services that
you used to run your business and you
want to load it into a cloud database
like bigquery or something and you know
since this is the modern utl process you
tend to do the load first copy the data
into your cloud database and then you do
various transformations basically
refining the data into datasets that you
can then use for whatever stand stream
so since this is a cloud database it's B
it receives sequel queries but if we add
users to the picture they probably don't
want to speak sequel they may be able to
speak sequel they may be comfortable
they may be so somewhat comfortable but
it may not be the most efficient tool
for the job so
probably for interactive business users
but they probably want some other
language some higher-level language so
you can kind of see the same pattern
emerging here of having a low-level
language and we need a higher-level
language to make things easier for users
and to make things easier to manage so
if we if we go back to this old old
diagram of the file system versus the
DBMS I'd argue there's the same kind of
progression from the DBMS to the
analytic system where the DBMS is the is
in the heart of the analytic system but
we've got a high-level declarative
language on top of it and the difference
is the the the intended users for this
analyst you know are happy writing
sequel statements business users may not
be it may or may not be able to but
they're more comfortable in a working in
a higher-level language whereas
programmers want to you know write
programs that access the individual
bytes of the file so let's look at some
of the tricks that databases use and
we'll see the kind of parallels to that
to how those tricks could be used in the
in the in the overall system so one of
the main tricks is reorganizing data
often it means creating a redundant copy
of the data so one of which is taking
the file and sorting it in a particular
order and then when you've sorted it
so you I don't know whether the text is
you know easy to read so we've we've
we've sorted it on a BCC the keys are
now in sorted order we can add an index
which basically tells us where is the
first record that starts with a where's
the first record that starts with C we
can partition the data in other words
for odd-numbered records over here
even-numbered records over here we can
replicate the data so we can have one
copy of the data in Tokio another copy
of the data in New York that kind of
thing or perhaps just have one copy of
if we've got a small table that
everyone's joining to we have one copy
of that data in every node in the system
so we can join to it and then lastly
summarization which is creating your
table which is something which is
grouped by which is rolled up on
water or month or Department or or
whatever these are all tricks that are
creating redundant copies of the data
often it's the whole data set or perhaps
it's created by some query on the data
set and then lastly caching which I
would claim caching is basically a
process of copying data from disk into
memory you don't change its logical
content be obviously change its physical
format you change it into a format which
is suitable for memory and I claim that
caching is really just it should belong
on the previous page because caching all
you're doing is reorganizing data you're
converting it into a different physical
format so it has different
characteristics it's in storage which is
much more expensive but has a lower
latency so I claimed you know the
database makes the decision to bring
some data into memory and it makes the
decision to not flush it out of memory
it's basically doing a table data
optimization in this in the same in the
same way as those previous ones briefly
I'll introduce a patchy calcite which is
a project I found it about six or seven
years ago it is a framework for building
where you can think of it as a kind of a
template for a database management
system it includes a sequel parser but
the heart of it is an implementation of
relational algebra and a query
optimization framework and it's used by
a lot of projects and products people in
the same way that no one writes a parser
from scratch these days if you're
writing your database it makes sense to
start off with a relational algebra
system you tell it about your operators
you tell it about the query
transformation rules you want to apply
to those operators and Cal State will
basically help with the process you can
add your own statistics for example to
drive it along it's an Apache project
which means we work according to the
Apache community model which means there
are among those organizations that are
using this and contributing to it
there's a lot of companies which are
competing with each other
apache provides this level playing field
so that these people can work
collaboratively and not you know not
conflict so relational algebra is a kind
of mathematical underpinnings behind
sequel and most other query languages
it's based on set theory and it's its
base it's a set of operations that you
can do on sets such as filtering a set
applying a function and only leaving
values in the set which which fulfill a
condition so that a sequel where Clause
is a basically a filter aggregate
operation is like group I so this is the
kind of the raw building blocks that
calcite and and the query optimization
rules are dealing with and the way
calcite optimizer works which is the
industry standard way of doing this is
by algebraic rewrite so you have rear we
have algebraic transformation rules that
recognize particular patterns in the
algebra and then rewrite it to something
which has the same semantics in other
words it always produces the same
results as the original query but it may
we hope be more efficient so in this
particular case just flicking between
these two slides we've taken a filter
and we've pushed it down into one side
of a join which means there are fewer
records going into the joy and therefore
the join is probably faster but combine
this with maybe a hundred other rewrite
rules and you can start to do some
pretty significant improvements to to a
query plan so view one of the other
thing that calcite and sequel provides
is views so I when you define a view in
real in in sequel what you're basically
doing is defining a relational algebra
expression so when you define this view
called managers when I when I use
managers in a query managers looks like
a table but actually what I'm saying is
when I include
what looks like the scanner scanned of
the table of managers in their query
what I actually mean is I want you to
substitute this blob of relational
algebra in its place so it's it's
basically telling the system to do tree
substitution and this is a useful thing
because it allows you to kind of hide
the complexity of your application you
don't have to include that query every
time you want to do a query on managers
it doesn't talk cause any data to be
stored so it's something that happens
all of the magic happens that prepare
time in the query but it makes your
application simpler so after expansion
we've now got a project that's reading
from a join ok materialized view is
another important concept and
unfortunately it has a very similar name
to view but it's almost the exact
opposite so when you create a
materialized view it does store data on
disk so when I say when I create this in
materialized view M summary I'm saying
in addition to the employees table I
want you to create this other table with
employees group by Department number and
gender and just leave it there because I
might want to use it in some future
queries and unlike create table I select
which is fairly similar the system
actually remembers where this data came
from and it maintains that relationship
if I update the employee's table the
system will also update the the
materialized view so that when a query
comes in this query is doesn't reference
a reference is the employees table it
doesn't reference the M summary table in
fact the person who wrote that query may
not know that M summary existed but the
system is smart enough to realize that
this is something that can be answered
using the M summary table and the M
summary table is smaller
therefore it is able to rewrite it and
in order to rewrite it it's it's it's
actually quite a complex process that
the optimizer has to recognize in the
query this common sub-expression which
is the same as
the the defining expression for the
materialized view and because those are
identical they can then substitute the M
the M summary table into that part of
the query we still got a filter on top
of it and in some cases you actually
have to rewrite the query a little bit
to make what the the lower parts of the
query identical to the materialized view
nevertheless it's an incredibly powerful
thing actually database index is in the
sense a materialized view it's a copy of
the data where you've just applied a
sort operation and projected perhaps a
smaller number of columns to it so
materialized views are one of these when
I was talking about these different ways
of organizing data materialized view is
this concept even if a database doesn't
call it that it's this concept that
allows the database to say hey you're
asking to you want you you've asked me
to query this data but I'm going to
query this data over here because I
happen to know it can answer your
question and it can do it faster okay
analytics so I work for looker so I'm
and you know my job is figuring out how
to make looker faster and easier to
manage and make the users happy and make
the data engineers that are populating
that allowing the whole organization to
be productive so look at the my examples
will be drawn from looker because that's
what's in my mind but all of this would
apply to virtually any analytic system
so in looker we look is based on a at
the heart of looker is a language could
look ml it's a text it's a basically a
programming language it looks somewhat
like JSON and this is how you define
your business views how you define your
data models so here we're defining your
view it's not a sequel view it's a it's
a business view called orders and it's
based on a implicitly it's based on us a
table called orders so we can define
that a bunch of dimensions and measures
and expressions and so forth and this is
the kind of high-level abstraction
there's another thing golden Explorer
this is the high level of abstraction on
top of your relational database by the
way people like paradoxically people
like writing code code is just easier to
manage than diagrams people like the
fact that you can dip it and merge and
store it and get and all that kind of
stuff and using this you can build
dashboards on top of these views and
then you can browse this is an explorer
which is basically a review of the raw
data but perhaps you can apply some
visualizations as well and lastly you
people tend to edit this in a web-based
IDE that gives you access to the code
but also gives you access to the model
and so forth so in that context where
we've got materialized we've got
business queries and we've got a model
which is consists of business views what
are these data flows which are going on
between these tables because that's that
that's the data engineering pipeline and
I claim that well the question is who is
actually responsible for making sure
these data flows happen who's
responsible for making sure this table
gets populated this job gets run and the
default answers the question is the data
engineers own it but that's not a very
satisfying question for anybody because
there are users who need a particular
table to be populated in order to run a
report and the data engineers are just
too busy to be able to respond to that
request and furthermore no one
anticipates that someone is going to
start and you know querying this ten
year old data set and therefore other
odd index is created for it so the
smooth flow of this data is a problem
that needs to be solved in order to make
everyone happy and furthermore this the
data engineering it's not a static
property it evolves over time people
that new reports
this you know you've got a data
scientist that wants to extract a file
from this from this system perhaps we
want to cache some data in memory so how
do we approach this you know the default
answer is this is all the responsibility
of the data engineer I would claim that
we want to kind of hand power back to
the users and let analyst control
certain aspects of this of this pipeline
to be able to create what they need the
system should be able to solve tune and
create data sets as it needs them and
sure the data scientist can write
programs in Python mode or whatever to
get the data that they need if we reduce
friction everyone gets what they need
they get you know they get to get home
they get to go home on time and the you
know the data engineers aren't just you
know frustrated because they seem to be
the cause of everyone's problems so
here's here's another look ml view but
what we've got inside this is this
construct called the derive table so
this is the this is the means by which
the analyst can get what they want and
we call it ETL light and I think it's a
it's it's a strength of looker but I
claim that it's it's something that
should exist in any analytics product or
any analytics architecture is this what
we've declared is this derived table so
we so we've declared this view on this
on this table called customer order
facts and it doesn't actually exist yet
so when someone uses this view in in a
looker Explorer or dashboard or whatever
the system will go and create this
create this table which is called a
derive table based on that sequel
statement so it basically does a little
mini ETL job and it's probably quick and
dirty and it's probably you know
it probably doesn't conform to the
enterprise's policy about you know when
you should be creating temporary tables
and so forth but it gets the job done
and at least it's on there in record in
the in the model file and it can be
upgraded to a real ETL job in due course
here's another kind of derived table
it basically is doing the same thing but
its source is not a sequel statement its
source is an explorer in other words
something i've defined somewhere else in
my look a model i'm defining a table
that contains a result of reading from
that business view so this allows me to
add richness it also adds me to allows
me to have efficiency because i'm
computing this thing once and it will
basically use this derive table until
the data goes stale so it's various
flavors of the rife table i've been
talking about persistent derive tables
here there's also something called an
ephemeral and persistent derive table is
kind of like a create table I select it
I mean when you first load up the
dashboard it literally does a create
table I select an ephemeral drive table
is kind of like a view in the it's just
expression expansion and the expression
will be substituted into whatever query
gets run in the system but it doesn't
create anything on disk so whether you
use an ephemeral derived table or a
persistent derive table it depends on
kind of amortization you know how how
many is it worth the effort of creating
this run in this expression once and
using it multiple times or if you're
only gonna run it once probably you
don't need to store it anywhere
and then lastly transparent arrive
tables which are I would claim are
analogous to materialized views so the
the basic persistent derive tables and
transparent derive tables are this is a
feature under development by the way
it's not currently in the product but
it's top of my mind and it's where we're
heading
it still creates it creates the same
amount of data on disk except that it
remembers where it came from and you can
use it in a query that doesn't reference
that that particular table by name which
means that you get this kind of magical
speed-up across the system for anything
that is accessing that data you don't
have to rebuild your existing business
models your existing reports you get
this magical speeder so making a this
process of tuning is a a complex process
and I'm not really gonna address you
know all of these points but just to
just to describe all of the things that
need to happen in order for this to work
somebody or something some system has to
figure out which materializations or
which derive tables to create as you
know as I described it there it is a
user the person that writes the look a
male model or in the case of a DBMS is
the DBA who writes to create
materialized view statements
somebody has to populate them with data
in the case of look where it's created
you know when when the when the data
goes stale it's recreated the next time
it's used we need to maintain it it may
be possible to maintain these things
incrementally depending on how complex
the expression is we may not be able to
maintain them incrementally we may have
to do a full reload somebody and that's
generally calcite has to see an incoming
query and realize that it can be
rewritten onto to use the materialized
view and that's a pretty complex piece
of logic that's required to do that
we're forever making that logic smarter
and the fact that there's a lot of
different companies and organizations
contributing to calcite means that we're
kind of sharing our intellect so you
know that is forever getting data but as
they say being a query option
as a person there's a job for life I
mean the problem is just never done we
need the system to adapt which is not
just I've looked at the queries over the
last month and I think we need this new
materialization
if someone's running dick day is running
an analytic session right now and
they're analyzing this data we want the
system to adapt to that to that pattern
of behavior now and you know not wait
until tomorrow so caching is a you know
famous is a simple and easy and
straightforward and pretty effective
form of adaptation where you read this
data it leads the data in memory and
therefore the next time I read it it it
comes back faster but caching you know
has limited power if the data you're
reading is you know a terabyte in size
and you don't have a terabyte of memory
and we need a rich algebra relational
algebra is pretty rich but if you if
you're dealing with things like you know
nested collections and windowed a great
functions and user-defined functions it
can be difficult for the system to keep
up and to be able to make all the
necessary rewrites it needs to here's
kind of a sketch of how calcite calcite
offers some support for designing these
summary tables so this is answering the
question of who designs the summary
tables the materializations
so calcite has a structure called a
lattice where you basically tell it
about a star schema you say this you
know in this case customers table is
joining to the the sales table is joined
to the customers in the product table
and the product is joined to the product
glass table and you say once you define
that you're basically saying to calcite
watch out for incoming queries that
access one or more of these tables and
watch the query frequency of you know
which watch for which roll-ups are
occurring more more often are people
often you know aggregating on the level
or you know zip code or whatever and
what will happen is it will start
recommending particular summary tables
at a particular level of aggregation
based on that lattice now this is I use
the word lattice because it's a it's a
you know mathematical concept of a graph
which has a top node in the bottom node
so let me just explain what the the two
of the terminology means so we've got
these you know simple example we've got
five columns at code state gender year
and month and the raw data is for the
sake of this example a million rows and
if we just say count star we get one row
back which is group by nothing if I
group by is by state I'm going to get 50
rows back if I group by state and year
I'm gonna get five times 50 I'm going to
get 250 rows back so this is a high
level of aggregation this isn't more
granular every single item in this graph
is a possible group by clause and
therefore a possible summary table we
don't want to build all of them there is
a property that if you for example have
a summary table on let's say year and
month we can roll that up to year so
that's what these like that the line
between y comma m and Y is basically
saying we can make that roll-up and the
numbers here are kind of estimates of
the number of rows that are going to be
in these things
zip code and state thus fewer
combinations of ZIP code in state than
you'd expect
because they are they're correlated
right most almost all zip codes don't
cross the state boundary where as year
and month are completely uncorrelated so
that the number is that multiplying the
two cardinalities together
if we take all attributes combined we
would expect them to have you know
probably I don't know ten million or 20
million values but the answer is only
nine hundred and twelve thousand because
they're only there zone we're only
sampling from a million records
therefore the comp possibly might be
more than more than a million
combinations so that there's I'm gonna
in the interest of time I'm going to
skip over this there is now rhythm to
design these summary tables based on the
based on the statistics it's a pretty
well-established algorithm it works
statically you don't have to see what
queries have been run but it will
produce something like this which
basically suggests the orange ones are
the summary tables that's decided to
create and you can kind of see if you if
you move from the top to the bottom by
any particular path you can only hit one
orange orange ellipse which which is
obvious if you think about it once it's
basically built actually well if there's
one one down there but once you for
example built the the year and month
summary table there's no particular
reason to create the year summary table
because year in month summary table is
small and you can very very easily roll
up so this is the optimization algorithm
that's doing is choosing the right
points to add these ok so back to this
idea of different people owning
different parts of the data engineering
pipeline we introduced this idea of a
derived table or a kind of tactical ETL
which is the goal of which is to reduce
friction even though it might let's say
circumvent the normal processes and in
the organization over time we can
restore order and basically take some of
the some of the the ownership of some of
these tasks can basically be moved
upstream so perhaps this thing that this
analyst needed and they created using it
systems arrived table on Monday bye-bye
Friday you know or maybe by two months
late
two months later we've moved it into the
official ETL process so now we can get
rid of that derived table the user is
happy because they've got the report and
the data engineer is happy because now
it's it's moved into our more it's
productionize and it's being done as
part of a nightly job and it's and it's
more efficient lastly we've moved one of
the tables that was being populated by
the system in the in demand from put on
demand from particular queries now we've
moved that upstream and maybe it's being
populated as part of the look on our
model so we've anticipated that need
rather than system having to populate it
on the fly so what we've been talking
about here is basically how to make
systems adaptive the goals are to
improve response time and give people a
rich model so they can answer they can
ask the questions that they want to ask
and get their results in a reasonable
reasonable time you also want the system
to be adaptive so that you get reason
youyou may be the first time you ask a
new question it's slow but the second
time you ask you that's fast and who
does this well really it's it's it's not
possible for the system to do it but it
has to be kind of a combination of
letting humans
tune the system let the systems adapt
automatically and then perhaps apps that
have some algorithms that will will help
with the tuning and I've spoken to many
adaptations materialized views are this
very broad pattern of tricks but caching
data in memory is always always an
option using secondary data structures
like indexes and other forms of
reorganization might change in your file
format so that's all I have
do we have time for any questions do you
see calcite growing in its scope or is
the problem big enough that it covers
right now to kind of you'll be busy long
term it's a it's growing in its scope
and its depth so people are using it for
Federation for example we've had a lot
of contributions recently from Alibaba
who are building a you know industry
industry strength engine called Max
compute they came out of the blue
they've been adding JSON support to you
know implementing the JSON functions in
calcite so the interesting thing about
open source is you can't really direct
where it goes you get various people
that join and they have a particular
thing they are interested in and they
contribute it and it takes you into
pretty interesting areas all I can do
and the existing kind of members of the
community can do is try and steer it so
that the calcite is not becoming
something that it shouldn't be but you
know if we if we manage the code well
then it can be a lot of things it can be
many things to many different people
[Music]